they're just vaccinating the kids
I need to know this is Chrissy chaos you
know vaccines are in the news I know
you've been Googling it I know you're a
big fan of RFK Jr a man of the people
you know how the Kennedys are yeah yeah
just people of the working class the
Kennedys I support the calf folks I'm
sorry
can I tell you I just I listen the RFK
dude is quite interesting everything you
know I watched the Rogan stuff and I'm
curious about it but I do get a little
bit of um I don't know a discomfort at
Kennedy saying that they're like out
here for the working class right because
they're like the young Kennedys have you
know been partying in New York for a
while sure and they don't exactly party
work in class and I won't say which one
but there's an iconic story in the city
of one of the young girl Kennedy's
trying to go out to a nightclub and they
wouldn't let her in and she said out
loud
the airport's named after me
[Laughter]
that's true that's true that's true
I don't think I know what's going on
because I have I've been a little bit
outside the news because again with kids
you don't you can't really do what you
want to do you're in fourth place in
your own life what's going on
what's going on he went on Rogan and
what happened are the Kennedy's coming
back
I don't know okay I think we're seeing
why they're all dead
but then you go and you see the Rogan
episode you're like oh yeah he's taking
shots at everybody yeah yeah yeah I
gotta watch that Rogan episode I haven't
been uh I have because you know
basically saying the covid vaccine might
be a little fugaze I don't really
oh for me with the getting the kids
vaccinated I personally yeah personally
because you know I believe in God the
Creator so I'm like listen if whatever
God's Little immune system God made my
kids fat he vaccinated them before sent
him down down the shoe yeah so my thing
is like let my children's immune system
do their job if we reach a point where
it's very clear that we need to get
modern medicine involved we'll get
modern medicine involved yeah this whole
thing of here's the thing I have zero
issue it's the same reason why I I
picked you know Ryan holiday and the
daily stoics advice because it's 2 000
years old it's battle tested as opposed
to a new age thinker who may or may not
be right but they haven't got the years
of experience so for me I'm like that
certain vaccines have got those years of
experience I got no issue giving my kid
this certain vaccines a flu shot or
anything like that that's been around
battle tested battle tested the new
vaccines it just hasn't been battle
tested you need to be battle tested yeah
I just need it I need some years before
I can do that you can buy the first
iPhone they get the Kinks out of it yeah
Jackson the latest coveted vaccine I
think did you get boosted do they even
sell that and stand on
you go to the Boost
Ed leather jackets
[Laughter]
Tour Updates London you already know
tickets on pre-sale right now code is
Andrew uh also this weekend we're gonna
be in Temecula California that's already
sold out and Reno we had a second show a
few tickets left for that one uh we're
gonna be adding more cities very soon so
stay tuned thank you guys so much for
coming out to all these shows uh
incredibly excited and Toronto thank you
guys so much that was unbelievable man
uh both shows at the Scotiabank Arena
sold out uh thank you so much incredible
incredible incredible and uh let's keep
cooking man more dates to be added very
soon
peace also guys big announcements tour
wise first of all I am taping my first
full-length one hour special in Houston
at the White Oak Music Hall September
1st the first show sold out within 24
hours y'all are amazing so we added a
second show but those are almost gone as
well so hurry up and buy your
ticketsing.com also there's a lot more
dates on there that you can find
including some new dates I think we
added we moved Salt Lake City we added
Poughkeepsie but more importantly Zanies
y'all sold that [__] out so fast that we
added two more shows so July 13th is
sold out but we added the 14th and 15th
I believe you might need to check your
calendar but the Friday and Saturday
shows we added to Zanies so go to Akash
singh.com buy your tickets for Zanies
buy your tickets for the special taping
we're elevating the [__] out of this
year I love y'all thank y'all so much
now let's get back to the show you know
it's unfortunate the government put put
us in that predicament it's unfortunate
that they did that not us yeah and uh
but yeah but I'm not I don't think you
know the booster now you know you hear
about all these problems I'm just like
you know what I'll take a shot I'll take
a shot at you know my own immune system
doing what it does you know and uh and
there's no part of you that's like it'd
be kind of cool like seeing the success
of of a lot of autistic people there's
no part of you that like you see it as
an advantage oh make no mistake I when I
was our way to compete with China
yeah make no mistake when I was a
pediatric physical therapist you know I
I worked doctor yes doctor yeah I mean
of physical therapy so it's like oh come
on come on come on man yeah
on the pot a little bit Dr D stuff all
right all the real doctors at home are
saying the same thing
[Laughter]
we have a medical professional to talk
about this yeah
yeah but I'm a nurse but so the only
thing
my man just took away his doctor
to be honest with you it's like if it if
it was that important to me I would have
the diploma I don't even know where my
diploma is I have no idea where that
diploma is I'm not [__] on physical
therapy I think it was a great
profession but yeah you're not a real
you have to be very clear I have a
clinical doctorate is so different from
what actual real doctors or even nurses
dude I would
in the bucket hat before you went to
it then go to Dove because
the Jewish guy then the physical
therapist
um but but yeah I uh when I worked with
the children who had autism dude I
almost felt like they're so smart and
they're operating at such a different
wavelength that it's not so much that
wait why'd you work with the kids with
autism oh because Physical Therapy out
of them no no I tried I'm about
dodgeball and just let one rip
I know you're Faking It
all different kinds of kids you have
kids with cerebral palsy so those you
know the kids throw them in there
at all funny literally my second day on
the job this principal calls me to the
office she goes Chris how's everything I
was like it's good I'm loving it having
fun she goes it's great because we're
having a good time because I just have
to remind you again you cannot run up
and down the hallways with the kids
holding them like footballs
and then Spike them into bean bags
because I was the only
that's oriented profession so I was the
only guy I was the only guy there so I
mean I was having so much fun with these
kids but she was like again you know
some of these kids are feeding tubes
they have issues and you're having a
good time and we're but it's a liability
yeah so but the children with autism you
would work with them you know they
needed you know motor skills or they
needed to you know they would have
weaknesses here and there and I was like
man these kids they're they just can't
communicate but I would always Fascinate
I'm like what is happening in their
brains because they'll be able to like
focus on something for like you ever
seen like The Blair Witch yeah when uh
like I forgot which one it was where
like there's the The Witches just
looking at something for four hours like
she's just and it's creepy to see
someone just stare they would do that
sometimes like yo something Monumental
has to be happening in their brain for
them to just be staring at something you
whatever for uh and you cannot break
their concentration I'm like something
something wild so the witch just had
autism that's what it is the witch just
had autism the big umbrella this the
term autism I think it's a spectrum they
don't even yeah they're just on the
autism spectrum and also it's it's a
spectrum but not in the way that like it
gets worse no or that's not what they
mean by Spectrum it's not like oh you
got a 99 out of 100 or you're like a 200
they're just different ways you could be
autistic so some people got the math
autism some people they're just staring
and then they do nothing autism make no
mistake I mean make but doesn't it seem
a little umbrella like I feel like
there's different things that are also
wrong and we're just oh no you you can
go the the talent so many talented
people on the Spectrum I mean Zuckerberg
Elon Rock Chris Rock rock my new Chris
Rock I felt weren't they ruining it for
actually autistic people because now we
look at the autistic people and we're
like what the why aren't you smart like
call yourself something else or just be
quiet about it because you're not
normalizing them right they're just
looking like losers right right like
you're kind of an [__] if you're
successful and you claim autism right so
that you can get even more pass on the
back like you're the richest guy in the
world and you're autistic oh yeah yeah
it's so hard well I think a lot of
people now lean into something in there
they lean into autism like and now
everybody's you know if you do something
good or bad I'm autistic yeah you can
blame it on autism it's like you're not
can't you just be weird but having it as
being a little weird yeah there's
autistic people and then Elon Musk
sometimes I think I think they do it for
playing time like remember at the end of
the season in high school where you
throw the autistic kid in oh yeah like I
think that some of the the worst
basketball players in high school are
just being like yeah I got it bro like
can I get a few minutes
you want garbage time yeah I remember I
remember one time when I was I played
college basketball you know it was
division three very low division three
so I was playing like it's you always
discredit yourself if you are
all-American would you not it's not it's
not were you not All-American I won
division three I just wanna I just want
to be clear it's very cash just like I'm
a doctor I'm not
I'm not like just like I want to be
clear from what he said in the beginning
please come out September 23rd to
serious but it's the baby garden okay
it's not it's the little let's see the
big one okay but but we're but first of
all together it's a it is a big huge
venue still we're not talking about it
about five thousand cheese yeah come on
okay so let's not just yeah I saw I took
the kids to see Coco Mel in there last
year oh yeah that's what dude so Coco
melon sells out bro cocoa melon is huge